joined Now by The Shadow Attorney
General of course Emily Thornbury hi
it's good to see you thanks for joining
us
um let's talk about strikes to start
with um just chatting to the leader of
aslef he says there's nothing on the
table that will stop their members going
out on strike again
Dreadful isn't it
I just don't think that this government
takes it seriously I think somehow or
other they think that they can just wait
it out that somehow or other people will
turn against them and then the workers
will just go back to work it's not going
to work it doesn't that's not how it I
mean
I don't understand it I don't understand
why they don't sit down and have some
serious talks and why they haven't been
doing it for a long time you know and
why we've ended up with these strikes in
the first place you hear from the unions
that they will negotiate with the
employers but they know that the people
who are really pulling their strings
behind the scenes are government
ministers who seem to turn up at the
last minute and say oh actually we've
got to deal with driverless trains or
you know looks like you two might be
getting on a bit too well we're going to
stick this
you know this this problem right in the
middle of your negotiations I think is
irresponsible I sometimes think that
they don't want the strikes to end and I
don't know why why are they doing this
well I suppose the government would say
as far as certainly as far as
um public sector pay is concerned that
is decided by the independent pay review
process do you think it is independent
well
so so you have an independent pay review
process and sometimes governments pay
attention to it and sometimes
governments don't and one of the way
sometimes you might get a government who
might say well we have the independent
pay review process but since then we've
had a spike in inflation so perhaps we
need to think again about it but this
government is not doing that they're
hiding behind the independent peer
review process and expecting people to
effectively have a pay cut and when you
have exhausted tearful nurses expected
to carry on and feeling like they're
being taken advantage of and taken for
granted you begin to get an undermining
of the National Health Service in a way
which nobody wants
talk how independent is the labor party
though because the government could
point the sort of money that you guys
get from the union so obviously you've
been seeing what we've been doing with
our Westminster accounts unite 8.8
million units and 4.6 million GMB 4.1
million on on it goes
well I mean it's no secret you know it's
in our name with a labor party we were
created by working people in order to be
a voice for them but we are independent
of the trade unions in that they can't
tell us what it is that we know no one's
ever tried to tell me what to say I mean
we don't get that from the Trade union
movement but they know that it's in the
interests of working people to have a
labor government and indeed it's in the
interest of everyone in my view to have
a labor government so they will support
us
um in in the work that we do and we will
obviously consult them and and the you
know the the common sense that that many
trade unions have because of their
connection with with their membership is
something which and why should anybody
be embarrassed about I mean I think it's
important to hear what they have to say
well given that you get 20 million quid
or there about it's from the unions even
when you get back into power does that
mean that the unions will have much more
power
I think that what will happen is that
they will get the sort of government
that working people need I think that we
will be a party that will that won't
allow strikes to happen in that way we
will sit down and talk to the unions at
an earlier stage we won't have these
stupid standoffs I mean when we were in
power or during the whole time we were
about we didn't have strikes in the
National Health Service we had a
National Health Service that was that
was a one to be proud of and you know
very few people took out private medical
insurance because they knew they were
going to be able to get the treatment
that they needed within a timely way
within the NHS and that's sort of NHS
that everybody wants
um why is it that the SMP is taking the
lead on reforming
um second jobs and other income for
politicians and not the labor party
I don't think they are necessarily I
mean I think that we've been saying for
some time that we would not want MPS to
have second jobs and if we are given the
opportunity to serve the public and a
couple of years time we will reform the
system and care has said for a long time
that he doesn't think MP should have a
second jobs I mean there are exceptions
obviously you know if you're if that
what you're doing is writing a book or
hosting a radio program you know
encouraging political debate bringing
more people into politics then obviously
that's a different thing but you know
being an independent being an advisor to
to a company and being paid a large
amount of money for that is not really
on so you know being an MP ought to be a
full-time job we do want to restore
faith in politics and we have a number
of ideas that you know we want to set up
an independent ethics commission for
example we think that that ministers
should be declaring and their interests
and the way that MPS do and it shouldn't
just be left to the ministerial code
which is policed by the Prime Minister
we don't think that's enough it we think
that they should be on a par with all
other members of parliament David Lammy
then where are we with Mr Lammy he takes
money for advising companies like JP
Morgan
well I mean as I say Keira's made it
clear what it is that he thinks that
people should do and and uh and if we
get into Power he will we will change
the rules we will make it clear that you
know that an MP should have
um their their job should be a member of
parliament it should be a full-time job
and you know the work that David does
with writing books and yeah
no no absolutely and I'm just saying
that that's an exception but here has
made it pretty clear what his views are
he is you know Consulting on it we do
want to make sure that our policy is a
good one
um but it will be I mean it will we're
not having any messing around you know
we will be firm about that so just to be
clear when a NIV labor come to power in
two years time there will be no more
opportunities for MPS to get consultancy
fees
that is not what we want to do
so people like um David Lammy will not
be allowed to take money I don't know
about the circumstances I don't know
about what's going on with David and JP
Morgan's news to me but but I know what
Kier is saying and Kier is saying
exactly that this consultancy this you
know MPS essentially giving advice
because they're an mp2 an independent
company is not something which is right
and we have enough to do looking after
our constituents and if we are fortunate
enough to be in the cabinet that will
certainly be a more than a full-time job
um just talk to me about
um sakia's trip to Northern Ireland what
does he hope to achieve from that
Kira's worked in Northern Ireland for a
long time and has many friends there and
many connections what we're trying what
we've always tried to do is make a
positive contribution to what's going on
in Northern Ireland we seem to be able
to talk to many people with ease
sometimes we think perhaps more than the
government does
um we think that you can learn a lot
when it comes to how we're going to
solve the issue of as having left the
European Union and with Northern Ireland
being on the border with with Europe
um we seem you know there are many
people in Northern Ireland who have real
practical Solutions as to how it is you
Import and Export across that border you
need to learn from them and we've put
forward a number of solutions that have
been urged on us and if you're living
there you know and it's it's your
preoccupation you could you know people
have been sitting there working on being
creative small businesses have got
suggestions and what we hear from them
quite often is that the government
doesn't listen we will listen we will
put forward their suggestions we will be
advocates for them in order to be able
to try to find a proper solution because
in time for the good the 25th
anniversary of the Good Friday agreement
we want to have an agreement with the
European Union that's going to work
always great to see you thanks very much